[Música]
hola bienvenidos a enlace andino soy
daniela blandón y los saludo desde
bogotá la capital de colombia
dedicamos a este programa a las
elecciones presidenciales que
concluyeron el domingo 19 de junio y que
le dieron el poder por primera vez a la
izquierda desde que este país andino se
proclamó como república independiente en
1810 hace más de dos ciclos también
analizamos quienes serán las cabezas del
equipo que llega al palacio de nariño el
presidente electo gustavo petro un
economista de 62 años y su
vicepresidenta francia márquez abogada y
lideresa ambiental quien se convierte en
la primera mujer afrodescendiente en
ocupar el segundo cargo de mayor
importancia
finalmente veremos los cambios
económicos y sociales que pretende
impulsar el próximo mandatario de los
colombianos y los retos a los que se
enfrenta bienvenidos
[Música]
i
y la tercera fue la vencida para gustavo
petro urrego con el 50,4 de los
sufragios en segunda vuelta que
equivalen a cerca de 11,3 millones de
ciudadanos se convirtió en el presidente
más votado en la historia republicana de
la tercera nación más poblada de américa
latina'
me llamo
gustavo petro
y soy su presidente
fue militante de la extinta guerrilla
del m-19 hasta que este grupo firmó la
paz en 1990 y recibirá las llaves del
palacio de nariño de manos de iván duque
un gobernante de derecha que afrontó
durante su jefatura del estado el
estallido social más grande de la
historia reciente del país veamos que
piensan los ciudadanos sobre el nuevo
presidente lo primero que espero es que
este gobierno le cumpla al país le dé lo
que le ha prometido que parta de las
políticas que se dieron que nos
posicione dentro de un mercado económico
a nivel mundial pues la mayoría de todos
confiamos en el votamos queríamos el
nuevo cambio y fue lo que haya prometido
el progreso el trabajo el estudio para
los muchachos que éste mejore la
economía para llegar hasta este punto
gustavo petro tuvo que vencer en unos
reñidos comicios a su contrincante
rodolfo hernández este magnate de la
construcción de 77 años le apostó al
populismo para tratar de conquistar la
mitad más uno de los votos
ahora damos un vistazo a quien
complementa por ahora el equipo
presidencial de petro hablamos de
francia márquez quien lo acompañará en
la vicepresidencia
esta abogada de 40 años nació en el
departamento del cauca zona donde el
conflicto armado ha estado presente por
décadas desde muy niña se ha dedicado a
la defensa de sus territorios
ancestrales lo que entre otras cosas le
valió para ganar en 2018 el premio
goldman considerado nobel medioambiental
tras haber hecho parte del equipo que
fue a la habana a negociar el acuerdo de
paz con la antigua guerrilla de las farc
y luego de apoyar activamente las
protestas antigubernamentales contra el
gobierno de duke francia márquez dio el
salto a la política y en poco tiempo se
convirtió en un verdadero fenómeno
popular
a gustavo petro no le esperan cuatro
años fáciles colombia es un país que
como la gran mayoría trata de
recuperarse de los críticos efectos de
la pandemia de sus 50 millones de
habitantes casi 20 millones están en
situación de pobreza 6 millones de ellos
en pobreza extrema se enfrenta además a
un acelerado aumento de los precios de
la canasta familiar que hoy están casi
un 10 por ciento más altos que hace un
año y un desempleo que no baja a un
dígito desde que inició la pandemia si
algo quedó claro en estas elecciones
presidenciales en colombia es que es un
país dividido
polarizada de hoy al que le esperan
grandes retos en los próximos cuatro
años por eso estamos con sandra borda
analista política profesora de la
universidad de los andes sandra gracias
por atendernos los colombianos salieron
a las urnas esperanzados en que va a
haber un cambio usted cree que va haber
un cambio sea para bien o para mal pero
habrá un cambio en colombia pues yo creo
que si la pregunta es de qué dimensión
que tan profundo y ese es ese es el
sitio en donde creo que gustavo petro
tiene la obligación de empezar a
contarle a la gente que el cambio rápido
abrupto radical no va a poder suceder no
va a poder suceder porque no hay los
recursos disponibles para hacerlo porque
se necesita transitar por el ámbito
institucional y eso requiere tiempo
pero yo creo que el compromiso que él
tiene con la gente es justamente el de
atender las demandas de la protesta
social que son demandas por un estado
que responda mucho más eficientemente a
las exigencias de servicios de la gente
entonces o eso pasa o empieza a pasar o
simple y sencillamente la izquierda se
puede ir despidiendo en su experiencia
en el poder por un buen rato hay una
oposición que ya declaró que va a ser
fuerte que puede esperar gustavo petro
de esa oposición el único problema es
que son minoritarios electoralmente y
son minoritarios en el congreso el
centro democrático la derecha quedó
reducida a una fuerza muy localizada en
el congreso yo creo que sin duda van a
ser una oposición vocal y fuerte no en
todos los casos comprometida con los
principios democráticos porque ya tienen
antecedentes de haber hecho cuando se
estaban negociando el proceso de paz
pero creo que no va a ser un obstáculo
enorme y en medio de todo yo creo que es
sano que haya una fuerza política que
esté ejerciendo veedurías y que se esté
siendo constantemente crítica desde mi
punto de vista sería muchísimo mejor si
fuese una oposición apegada a los
principios democráticos
pero pero yo no creo que vayan a
constituir un obstáculo enorme para que
él logre cosas en el congreso si pueden
tener un impacto en la opinión pública y
si lo pueden descartar desgastar en
materia de legitimidad como ven no son
pocos los retos que le esperan al primer
presidente de izquierda en la historia
de colombia tendrá desde el 7 de agosto
cuatro años para ejecutarlos y para no
defraudar a quienes lo llevaron al poder
hasta que este programa enlace andino
recuerde que puede ver este y otros en
france 24 y france24 puntocom